now I haven't finished my diagram yet
and that's intentional the reason why is
because um I'm just looking around a lot
of your diagrams are well it could be
better partly because I mean I think
we're quite good at drawing log grass in
fact what gets really fun to draw
because mostly if your right hand is
like me which is most of you um you just
go fully it's just doesn't see if you're
left handed and more awesome then I'm
sorry your hips don't quite go but now
when you draw this right you have a
curve you know where the coordinate axis
that's relevant is and then can get this
now a lot of you people have done this
in and quite a four spot which is led to
you like wandering away though I'm not
the area right or not because the scale
doesn't match what you're expecting it's
not hard to do this accurately it's
really not that difficult you know
roughly what this number is to two
decimal places is 2.7 1 i'd rather go
into to destin places 2.72 vacuole a bus
routes it's gonna be about here right
that point is going to be one you know
it has to be one quits the intercept so
you go that distance again to get to you
go at that distance again to get three
and then that gives you a plot where 2.7
is right just little tricks so that you
can make your picture but more like what
it's supposed to look like so there's
eight so here's the actual area then i'm
interested in a cake now i should call
that something called hit hey now the
first thing i would say from this is
exactly the same thing i was head from
this oh I have an area I know how I
workout areas on the curves I form an
integral okay now forming the integral
for this is really simple I enough to do
this work with that one over there
because i have x boundaries right so i
would say hey it was the integral frog
way to where usual way to where I
couldn't eat one by the way that would
just give it to me I'll be integrating
backwards I get many vanilla I will be
the same magnitude but i might as well
just go for a mutable okay then i'll
look at the function is it you've
entered the other area oh this is the
integrand right and then you pause right
now a lot of you I noticed Stan hey
cool I know what to do with log X i put
a rule about log accident box I'll just
do this because that's what I do with
like eggs I don't know but it wasn't
doing a blog it it just happens that
that's extraordinarily an awful what
have I done I'm differentiated I
integrated I've said this to many of you
before um because we have learnt about
these two processes together it is easy
to confuse them but they so don't feel
bad if you have done it I've done this
hundreds of times okay but it's not
right it's not right and you can clearly
see because if i differentiate this what
do i get actually you know what i get
minus 1 over x squared certainly not the
internet knows expensive so what that
means is at this point at least as
extension one students even is extension
to students at the point of course you
are you're kind of sunk okay you you
cannot get evaluate this integral but
that's okay remember we said right at
the beginning that longs and exponential
are really two sides of the same coin
right everything we know about
Exponential's we can apply it's a lot
there's an exponential graph hiding in
this curve it's just not that obvious
right all I have to do is rearrange this
equation here every log equation is an
exponential budget in disguise how would
I write that if i rearrange this with X
is the subject this is the same equation
I've just made extra subject instead of
why okay now the reason this is useful
is because if I have it as a function in
why I'm not limited to compared to the
x-axis I can compare to the y axis
remember that so we're used we're so
used to thinking about areas like this
right you need to get Y with respect to
X that compares you to the encounters
and sure enough that's what this area is
trying to lend you toward thinking right
but it's not the only way we can compare
it to the y axis that's going this way
right now the only slight problem with
that is that i don't know what to
compare it to the y axis this is the
area i'm gay
Yeah right now black part is comparing
to the y axis that's not the area I want
but it's close enough to the area I want
right if I can work out that black pot
what will I do it I was subtracted from
this rectangle what's the area of this
rectangle as it happens I already know
what the width of the rectangle is you
can crunch the numbers feather easily to
find out the high up there is one so the
area of this big rectangle here is e
then I want to work out the black area
and subtract it then I'll get my green
area okay so let me show you how i would
do this i'm going to say and by the way
there is no reason why i cannot simply
retain like i'm just going to leave that
line of work event it didn't help me but
the next thing i'm going to write is
exactly equal to this integral they're
the same thing okay i'm going to do this
by subtraction so i'm going to work out
one like I just said what is the area of
this rectangle even though it's obvious
i'm going to write 1 times e because
it's a rectangle with two dimensions and
just to make it clear we're leavin from
and then i'm going to subtract an
integral okay now because i'm now going
to compare this to the y axis I better
have Y boundaries right so I'm going to
go from nought to one and what did I
just establish I'm going to be
integrating X with respect to Y there's
X right there okay you happy with that
so there's X with respect to Y pause
before we do any of the machining on
this does it make sense you see how I
formed this right it took a bit of a
leak to say I can well I can't use this
in its current form a better put it in
form that I can work with ok and now i'm
just going to evaluate like we
established already they actually
rectangle is e e to the Y when you
integrate it becomes equal Y somewhat
easier to integrate the log X right and
we evaluate their ban e take away
another one take away a 20 yeah that
looks to me like a tango 8 plus 1 is 1
which you should be suspicious about
right those of you who look at is like
right way you're on a second you you
worked out the same area I'm 10 minutes
ago I just tried to hide it from
remember I said oh you don't need a
y-intercept here in earlier right the
reason I wanted you not ever done is
because it makes it obvious what is this
y intercept what's the y intercept
usually if you don't receive much
usually the y intercept is 1 and because
we're vertically shifting it downwards
Eve units this is 1 minus P okay now
keep in mind I'm below the axis so this
is a negative number right this is
actually a [ __ ] number what's the
distance it Z minus 1 right because it
is 2.7 Bob laughs so that's at one point
seven ish a minus one minus one where's
e- one on this diagram it's right there
have you see that it's e minus one right
and you've got the same 021 it's the
same shape what am I done I'm on I have
yeah I have reflected it annotated you
provided she exactly like my sister yes
he's like high school it wasn't like he
had like
so yeah sure okay so I guess what we're
trying to run up against here is that it
is not a number in the way that one is
enough but it is in the same way it's no
less of a number then what is it noble
life if I if I have a look on my number
line right I can find exactly where he
is unambiguously besides that well I
could never write it exactly but that
doesn't mean I can't work with it in the
same way that I can't work with that I
can work with pine right I can never say
pie exactly because I'm going to go on
forever right but i can still know like
if I wanted some male accuracy I can
find it it's not like it's it's a
mystery and will never discover it it's
not like the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle cycle you can never know how
much it's fitting right you can know
exactly where it is you just probably
need a bit of time if you want to be
really accurate okay but it is just a
number just like any other I mean that's
the that's the mystery of why like you
know irrational numbers right the word
irrational we're too rational didn't
start off meaning what doesn't make
sense what start of many ways you can't
express it as a ratio but the first
people could encounter numbers said that
that doesn't make sense you can't have
numbers that you can't express these
ratios all the numbers we know about can
be expressed this like they might be
weird ratios but they've gotta be some
so that's why this word both means means
both comp expense ratio and because of
the history of where these numbers about
just doesn't make sense who can write
the heads around for the same reason
that imagine numbers are called an
imaginary like yeah yeah yeah you and
you're imagining numbers get on your
body right like they're there no more
real or actual life no more irrational
than any of the other wonders it just
harder to work okay oh I hope you don't
mind me I'm head showing you the same
area twice this is the kind of thing
that you will encounter don't be afraid
when you see something and you think
when can I do this you can't do it just
push a little more on what you know
how you can employ to